oh
we live shawty
yeah we love we're lying hey
what's goody hopper at first
oh there's music
there we go
hit him with the applause sound effect
we bike baby
we are back with our weekly joke
feedback hour ladies and gentlemen
welcome
back new faces and familiar faces alike
we already got peeps in here posting
their jokes i had people messaging me
like do we po can we post them early
like we they they don't want to miss out
on the joke doctor this time so all
right thanks for joining us again here
jerry
yeah my pleasure man it was a lot of fun
last time we thought i'd do it this time
and but no thunderstorms this time right
no power outages this time
lord willing
so what we're gonna do here my friends
oh jt said first time in the stream
welcome jt afternoon everyone says
payden
oh yeah we deep in here bob kirk hi joel
and jerry
so yes how this is gonna work
oh kelly grits said i'm able to see
jerry live yes
you know oh right the you know the the
the i don't know do you we call this the
hot breath the verse do you have a name
for your your universe do you call them
anything um it'll be probably just joke
doctor live
joke doctor live yeah i mean you gotta
yeah i think you've got a lot of
information
let that fire i might just do a couple
of lives uh do it once or twice a month
and
you just never know yeah once a twice a
month instead of every week maybe
maybe maybe we'll follow your lead
you're like wow you're doing a lot it's
a time it's a time thing right it's like
yeah you know i got i got these other
like get this guy i was texting with to
today where uh i'm helping them
construct a script for
you know and it's
[__]
you know it's like
trying to take something that's
and it's like okay we gotta restructure
the whole thing a lot of people don't
understand story structure and how to
get the information out in a pilot form
it's a lot of stuff to cover but you
can't be too long and a lot of people
you know when they write their pilots
just too much going on
ah they tried to make it you know it's
just very brain intensive but what do we
say we get to the jokes are we ready or
do you want to let's do it my friend so
yes how the name of the game is my
friends just post your jokes in the live
chat here and we will
do our best to give you as much feedback
as possible put the word joke in front
of it as well so we know
that it is a joke for us to read and
feel free to give each other feedback in
the comments as well for the next little
bit we're gonna land the plane at six
today so for the next little bit here
we're just gonna be trying to
help as many comics as possible here so
speaking of helping comics
uh the first joke we're gonna do is
gonna be mine because
i thought of this one
at my show over the weekend and i was
like i like this premise and i think
there's more to it so
basically it all came around of like
my uh my wife is starting to get baby
fever so that's a whole other thing but
um
basically the the joke i came up with
you need it's a van
say all i need is a van is that gonna
use a van you can get one
[Laughter]
so it's um
we started our family plan by having a
dog so i'm used to tripping over toys
okay why is it a poodle
i i was well basically my house is
covered in dog toys right now right
right oh yeah we had a dog then we had
dog toys everywhere and then the dog
died
so that's what the idea was that it's
like having all these dog toys around is
preparing me for having like children
toys all over the house right
i think let's see so say that say it
again from the start
so
my wife and i started our family plan by
having a dog
so i'm used to tripping over toys
but it's basically i guess the premise
i'm trying to work on is it's like how a
dog prepares for a child essentially
yeah yeah so there's a whole bunch there
right did you actually take some time
and list everything dog
because i think if you got if you got
yourself to get like radical or wild
with it like you know it's like um it's
like uh so uh i'm thinking what i'm we
what we should get as a choker collar
uh okay you see what i'm saying it's
like what would be for a dog but be
outrageously
outside the realm for an actual baby
uh yeah like well they both have leashes
but some people put their kids on
you also have uh um but you wanna like
it's like you thinking right now you're
thinking it's the naive guy right the
the guy who doesn't really know anything
it's like so you're actually going to
get something you would get for a dog
that would be wildly exaggerated for a
baby
as dan o'shannon the modern family uh
creators calls it go wildly exaggerate
you can always dial back a little bit oh
so even if it was like for a dog i mean
flea meds
breastfeeding came up to mind it's like
yeah dry food
dry food dog bowl
stroller potty training
right you see you see definitely see
people with uh strollers right and one
of the things i i realized gene parrott
used to say is like as we start to write
jokes a lot we're writing a lot of jokes
we have a tendency to fall into being
too logical
and so this happens and i notice i i
would do that i go wait a second if i
wildly exaggerate also there's the joke
and because i was trying to be too
logical or overthink the joke or be too
analytical or like i didn't want to go
yeah
too much but if you say it sometimes
boom it gets a big laugh and you go okay
maybe it is being i have to get to the
wacky part first
so it's like um so i thought you know so
i thought we'd start with a choker
collar you know or something like that
um
or
because leash is logical too many people
they already we see people kids on
leashes it's like that's just a that's a
person who's missing being a pet parent
uh um they also have doggy diapers they
have those for diet dogs doggy diapers
uh like um
you could even warm us up with the i'm
already tripping over the toys so i'm
thinking about hey we got the dog a dog
is a great warm-up to have babies like
you know the first thing i i'm going out
i'm but i would you know where do we go
shop for baby stuff anymore
baby you can't go to babies r us that's
not there right um babies r us they
don't they don't seem to have a call a
choker collar you know
start someone said shock collar as well
could be one shot collar
um
the the cone of shame
oh yeah one of those big cones yeah yeah
yeah that's yeah and i hadn't even
thought it through beyond like i kind of
i just kind of said that line on stage
and then i was like i'll bring it to
this today because i said on stage this
weekend of just like she's buying so
many clothes and so many toys to like
prepare me to like have a kid or almost
to hint at that hey it's time to have a
kid look at all these we they can be
hand-me-downs the
the toys and clothes could be
hand-me-downs to our our kid
there may be something there yeah they
could share clothes when you said toy i
was also thinking of toy poodle
uh-huh yeah yeah right yeah okay
oh yeah a muzzle
[Laughter]
payton said a muzzle okay yeah there's a
lot of muzzle would be good yeah so i
got the muzzle yeah it's like the dog is
warming up stuff warming i think it's a
great warm-up for a child like you know
we already got the baby muzzle
yeah
maybe a three-way build-up baby muzzle
choker collar and
sausages and sausages yeah kibbles and
bits yeah kibbles and bits like dry food
and kibble baby kibble what would that
look like because the babies have no
teeth but the dog does
oh yeah and you know i do have a bit
about how dog food is healthier than
human food now
yeah there's more vitamins and yeah they
they really enrich it
with more vitamins and stuff than than
we ever get for humans
so that could oh so that could all tie
in maybe there interesting okay
i like where that's headed yeah we got a
lot of good kind of good ideas out there
i'll try to um i'll try it on stage
tonight
because people are commenting with a lot
too very nice
yes
like that's great i love when they put
the comments in because
you can't think
you don't have everybody else's life
experience they could come up with
something you would never think of in a
million years
that's why i love rooms like all the
brainstorming goes on you have somebody
that will have any has an experience
that you would never think about coming
up with an angle like that you go ah so
we got the kennel
yeah yeah yeah kennel is the crib maybe
yeah the rainbow will be
those are funny words together too
so like so you it's like she was
thinking about a baby someone ran out
and bought a kennel
and she's like that's a kennel they both
start with the c word right they both
same sound
because remember if you take it from the
filter of being like completely naive
and thinking dog ties right in oh yeah i
got this
yeah cause i could so your whole filter
is
like baby face i'm like i'm an adult now
like i have jokes about being a beta
male of like i don't know i have no like
real masculinity so that could be part
of the naiveness of like i don't know i
mean
yeah i like i like the absent-mindedness
that's kind of a funny filter too
i like it's like if you say it say it
like it like that work around right you
say like you know how many people you
get you're an alpha male alpha male's
out here you're gonna you're an alpha
male male you know it's like uh it's
like and it's like i i'm a beta male
i'm i'm more of a i i think i'm more of
a delta male it's like any epsilons any
[Laughter]
trying to get to that i'm working my way
up i don't know if i'll ever get there
like
you know what i'm saying yeah oh yeah
let's say it like that once you say it
like a workaround people go oh i get
what he's saying instead of beta male
beta test a lot of people don't leap
there alpha male they get alpha male
compare and contrast beta male oh you're
one of those yeah so should we call you
steven tyler you have a lot of scarfs on
your microphone stand
you know
because he he like hit what that's one
of his claims to fame is like he he just
he's totally can identify with his
female side
right so maybe that's you right or maybe
you just you're just not macho
definitely not i'm starting to play on
that more and i like i i have four
sisters so i say i was practically
raised by cats and that always gets a
laugh so
there's a lot to that yeah hilarious
all right well i don't want to hog up
all the time but that was right let's
get
with their contributions remember when
you comment or tag and top somebody
else's joke it actually makes you a
better writer
absolutely always part participate
whenever you can in that because you
just get better and faster
absolutely amen to that so let's get
that first joke that's a non-gel buyer's
joke here we go
first up
we have alan michael harbor here we go
so first joke up
did you know that there's a band called
hot oh wait never mind that's not a joke
he's telling me there's a band called
hot breath
sorry
508 funny here we go
um
at my most depressed making breakfast in
the morning got me through the day until
my toaster broke it was impossible to
find one with a cord long enough to
reach the bathtub
so what if we set that up as sort of
like an outside force imposing itself on
you like for example um what if as the
therapist said you know at my most
depressed my therapist suggested
starting out every day with breakfast
just make some toast
and it's like and then you were like so
that's the solution given to you by an
expert and you're like
i tried but i can't find a toaster with
a cord long enough to reach the bathtub
now it ties into the depressed
and i think that's his solution being
depressed that overrides what the
therapist is saying or that's his
solution to what the therapist's
solution was that's his answer to this
do you see what i'm saying
yeah it almost adds more context and
like personal touch to the depression if
it is like a therapist almost diagnosing
him with like a toe just start out each
day with breakfast you know start with
some toast
even if it's just a little toast i tried
that but i can't find a toaster with a
cord long enough to reach the bathtub
i really like it dude that is really
funny 508 funny
that that's good start there very nice
all right
next up just big boned
everybody is using words and phrases
these days that i just don't understand
like woke cancel culture
pride month
hmm now i think
usually in a three-way buildup
it's a pattern disruption right right we
have two that established a pattern then
one that loudly goes off course i think
pride mar month fits too much with woke
right and so we almost see that we're
trying to figure out where okay where's
the disruption in the pattern
so what if we said you know what if you
want like can it's something obviously
um you should get uh you should really
understand like uh
these phrases i just don't understand
like woke cancel culture
casual sex woke cancel
culture um
like
if consent
consent
yeah yeah that's what i was trying to do
very quick word because i was thinking
like virginity or something yeah yeah
yeah around the same collecting on
not necessarily like reflecting on
someone else's
but yeah the third's got to be like a
surprising twist these are basically
kind of like oh what did you say
congruent would you say
yeah yeah cool like woke cancel culture
just the tip
just the tip yeah yeah yeah without
coming off creepy but
yeah there's a third a silly third and
people in the comments feel free um if
you guys could think of a third
for mr big boned here please by all
means
and uh we're gonna keep it moving so
sometimes you just ask yourself what am
i trying to say with this joke
and it's like i don't understand this
stuff and it's like or whatever
you know
very nice
all right next up hairy pike
this week a caver was trapped for 54
hours or at least that was the excuse
from doordash
a caver was trapped for 50
it's a it's a funny joke it's the idea
that's like i always love i i love door
i love doordash and ubereats like it's
fun to be able to look at that app and
know exactly exactly pinpoint the exact
time they're gonna show up to my door
with the wrong order yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's a good match it's like setting up
an anticipation for something then
shattering at that anticipation but i
like this 54 hours at least that was the
uh uh
for 54 hours well that was
that was the uh
excuse that the door dash drop you know
given by the door dash driver would like
that was the excuse that doordash gave
me
yeah yeah it's like according to my late
doordash driver or yeah something to
like tighten it up a little bit there
oh cool
come on
and make sure that doordash gave you
that excuse if that's missing excuse
from doordash for what
because they were delivering to you i
think there's a little vagueness
involved like that at least that's the
excuse doordash gave me
now we know it was imposed on you
it doesn't like do you think a different
example like caver
or something like i don't know if it
could be a little more grinder yeah i
didn't i was lost for a second on caver
who's a caver yeah exactly who goes into
caves explores caves a cave explorer
even if it was like a
20-car pileup or i don't know something
more related to
the doordash actually being late caver
just kind of it kind of took me out of
it a little bit well you could say there
was a man this week there was a man
trapped in a cave for 54 hours
that was me at least that's the excuse
that doordash gave me
or that could be that or that's how i
felt waiting for my doordash
something like that something like that
close
something like that
uh next up jack allen
uh when my granddad got cancer my gran
was by his side every minute of every
day
that was my gran absolutely no hobbies
i like that joke that's really
ambivalent
i met every day that was my grand
and especially if he delivers it like
very endearingly of like that was my
brand like it's gonna be sentimental and
then it was like no hobbies
yeah no side hustles no hobbies
it reminds me of a joke my uh this uh
one of my students was doing talk trying
to do she said my my girlfriend her
daughter
gave me it's like the sweetest thing
gave me her only trophy her only trophy
she ever got as a child she gave it to
me
that's love right there i said either
that's either you know that's it made
you think wow she's not that talented
only you know gave me her only trophy
you know what i'm saying sort of the
same way he goes with this joke here
that's a good joke yeah i like it
especially
and so again this is one of those things
in the delivery take it for the sweet
side use your emotion to take it sweet
and then flip it
absolutely no hobbies yeah and jack is
great at that sweet endearing smile so
that'll that'll play perfectly into his
style
um
hayden
peyton baggett i no longer refer to
myself as sad and single i now prefer in
a sexless relationship with myself
and then a tag tinder heard that and
sent me a self-help book
well what if we say like i'm no longer i
no longer refer to myself as
sad and single i now prefer
in a relationship with myself wait
a sexless relationship with myself so
you correct yourself on that you get a
relationship with myself you'll get a
chuckle and then wait a sexist
relationship with myself
yeah i like i want to come across as
being easy
uh yeah i don't put any or it could yeah
be um
i i thought it could also flip to
it's like i know i'm referring to myself
in a sexless relation i no longer think
i'm in a sexist relationship tinder
calls it sad and single or it could be
tinder diagnosing that i have to step
away one second yeah no problem
yeah i like that i think it could be
also flipped the other way too of sad
and single but tinder calls you sexless
relationship that could be a fun one
there
very nice very nice
yes no thunderstorm today as well said
payton
hilarious
and it's cali grits first time as well
hey
anyone if this is your first time
hanging out with us we do this live joke
feedback every single tuesday on this
youtube channel so go ahead and hit that
subscribe button where we do three live
streams a week
on this channel we have over 400
interviews with comedians like jeff
foxworthy andrew schultz mark normand
all of them so go ahead and subscribe
tell your friends the hot breath the
versus out ya
and of course jerry's been on the show a
few times as well so we have always
appreciate that
and let's keep it moving here my friends
looks like the next
you know we'll we'll we'll we'll we'll
give we'll give him a moment here we'll
make sure everybody gets that that joke
doctor treatment here
but while we are
hanging out here
if you haven't subscribed do that or
share the video hit the like button just
let the algorithm know that we out
shouty
everything good sir
yes sir i had a have a plumber here
beautimus awesome all right so the next
joke up
connor martin
i was drinking with my buddy when he
pulled out a bottle of maker's mark and
said this stuff right here separates the
men from the boys
there's no like misdirect it's like a
phrase right now yeah that right now
it's a setup like i was drinking with my
buddy
uh he pulled out a bottle of maker's
mark and he said this stuff right here
separates the men
from the boys
and then i looked at him and said i'll
hold on to it till you're 18.
[Laughter]
oh yeah i like that yeah yeah yeah
something like that right so
uh uh you know first of all i drink i
drink maker's mark i like maker's mark a
lot so i related to that immediately and
it's like the stuff right here separates
the men from the boys right and there's
some there's some more in there right
and it's like
what it is is kind of a benign
retaliation here the guy's trying to be
men from the boys like so i'll hold on
to it till your 18. yeah especially if
conor like if he has more of like a baby
face or something that plays into like
that naiveness more as well
yeah
so i'll hold on to it to you grow a pair
something like that you know what i'm
saying you could even attack his manhood
it's it's it's got it's friends so you
can you can get away those little
insults we give friends exactly
all right next up here we have
biteworthy
james webb space telescope now allows us
to see space more clearly than ever
what's even more clear is that anyone
who brings that up is a huge nourish
great opportunity for a
paired phrase or a mirrored phrase so we
can take that setup like james webb's
telescope now allows us to see space
so much more clearly like you know
anybody bring the is like what's even
like uh you're using clear again but use
it in the same
context or the same syntax like you
could see anybody who brings that up can
clearly be seen as a huge nerd
oh
see what i'm saying it's like you're
using the mirrored phrase and if i toyed
with that a little more i'd really it's
like just make that phrase so much more
like make them repeat each other's but
they're ending differently you know yeah
and that helps with word economy too so
it gets to the punch line quicker as
well
and repeating the phrase sets up an
acute expectation because when you
repeat the phrase the brain is
automatically expecting the same syntax
the same uh syllables the same ending
so you can really mess around with that
surprise
and that's why we call him the joke
doctor
beautiful
well said my friend
um michelle van dusen
my parents traveled a lot not that my
dad wanted to go my mom was just really
good at guilt trips
oh yeah
i like the word play there
yeah
or is it i wonder if it's um
it could be flipped though that it's
like my family went on a lot of family
vacations or as my dad called them guilt
trips
yeah
so it kind of like or what if my mom
would often pressure my dad to go on
family vacations
or as
as my mom oh as i'd like to call you
know or it's like my mom was just really
you know because my mom was really good
at guilt trips
something like that like make it
something your mom wanted to do
your dad was kind of reluctant
and yet uh but you know my mom was
really good at guilt trips
yeah and just yeah saying it right now
it's like two sentences like well like
my parents traveled a lot not that my
dad wanted to go just saying that more a
little more fluidly like you just did
kind of helps the flow of the joke as
well
i guess you could say my mom was really
good at guilt trips or whatever i i
really like that word play though that's
fun
my my mom would call them vacations my
dad would call them guilt trips yes
oh
nicely done there michelle yeah nice
joke
alan
michael harbour
my mother loves watching thunderstorms
because it reminds her of when i was a
baby everything being loud and wet
oh
i wonder if it's like instead of my
mother loves watching thunderstorms it
like my mom
told me
i remind her of thunderstorms
and then or like it reminds me of me as
a thunderstorms remind her of me as a
baby
just like something a little more
conversational
could have been her nickname for for her
my mother my mother's nickname for me
was thunderstorm
because uh when i was a baby everything
was always loud and wet
yeah yeah yeah there we go yeah and she
and they're like she would always hide
in the other room or something like
there's like other tags there could be
just based around thunderstorm
like every time like every time i cried
that the
dog would go hide behind the rocking
chair
yeah yeah the dog hiding yeah there it
is
but yeah i like i like his nickname
being thunderstorm that kind of gets to
it a lot quicker
we cooking today fam oh and um
franco says what's up jerry
what's up franco
and lina alva
said jerry the best of the best yes
indeed
that's sweet
awesome oh and you know what we didn't
um
[Music]
uh
connor said that wasn't the whole joke
the rest of his joke was i was like damn
they could have used some of that in the
catholic church
oh separate the men for the boys that
could still be a tag you don't have to
lose that yeah yeah yeah
if they replace wine with makers maybe
maybe the catholic church you know um
in the catholic church they replace that
wine with makers maybe the priest can
finally get it right yeah yeah yeah
right yeah but i like i like that you
can't mess around with them there i like
a little boy
yeah yeah i like him roasting his friend
and not just like a catholic church joke
you know right right but yeah i just
want to make sure he seemed a little
bummed we're like oh that wasn't the
whole joke i just wanted to make sure we
got that out there for him
um
jared
i saw an infographic online it said the
average penis size in the u.s is five
and a half inches the average in
ethiopia is seven and a half inches it
makes you wonder
how are they so good at marathons
so i saw another infographic online said
the average penis size in the us is five
and a half inches the average in
ethiopia is seven half inches
i think i should move to ethiopia
hang on one second
[Music]
yeah i like how are they so good at
marathons
maybe that is maybe instead of asking
maybe telling that explains why they're
so good at marathons
it's like a pogo stick or something like
it's something that third oh yeah they
have three legs
there it is cali grits yep
there it is
nice the plumber the housekeeper here
no worries oh look at other look at look
at jerry like flexing a housekeeper and
a plumber
it's like it's one of those days yeah
well yeah so yeah i now thought about as
i was walking away the ethiopian joke
it's like that would make you below
super below average
um
said uh it's because they have three
legs that's why they're so good at
marathons
i like that
that's good
very nice
all right well you can say that's why
they're so good at marathons they have
three legs yeah
i like that yeah yeah nice input
next up
joe
[Music]
keotic perhaps uh i always want things i
can't have when i was a few months old
my mom got sick so i went cold turkey on
breast milk so i'm a breast man now she
has a double mastectomy
way to kill a dream mom
got sick
breast milk
i'm not sure what he's trying to say
here
like the premise
yeah there's a lot going on there's
almost a couple of different jokes like
for example uh when i was a few months
old my mom got sick so i went cold
turkey on breast milk you got to make
sure the audience understands clearly in
an instant what you mean by that i got
cut off basically you know had to go you
know no more breast milk cold turkey and
it's like um now you know so i'm a
breast man because of desire because of
lack of you know because i want
something i ca i could never have as a
child it's like uh but now
now she's got a double mastectomy
so it's like
way to kill a dream
hmm i'd have to think about that one
yeah it's like or like i went cold
turkey on breast milk or as my mom
called it a double mastectomy a
mastectomy or
because if she it almost ties in if she
got if he had to go cold turkey she gets
a double mastectomy
huh
you know the um
and plus you're an adult so i'm like
you shouldn't be looking at your mommy's
boobies that way
oh yeah if it's like an age joke an age
misdirector yeah
all right
there you go joe
next joke i'm seeing here is from
oh this is this is someone did a tag for
that old power threes joke the woke
cancel culture and manners that was a
that's a funny
oh good yeah really good that's good one
there jordan
um this is coasting ghost
uh last night a lady pulled over to the
side of the road and started performing
the worst set of lunges
she was stumbling everywhere once she
stopped she turned around
and got arrested for a dui
i don't know where the connection
it's almost a story you got a story here
and it's not like
um
you know if we think it's a joke
we got to be misdirected thinking it's
like this lady actually got out of the
car and started doing lunges right there
on the side of the road lunges and i'm
like where were you were you able to see
this whole thing you know were you
driving by we did you stop too
it's like you know she's sitting there
doing lunches it's like she's stumbling
all around
and it's like um
it's like what does she expect to gain
from the lunges muscle tone what does
she instead you know she didn't uh she
didn't get she um
she didn't get her working and she
didn't really get a workout in she got a
dui that kind of thing cross-legged
to cross bars to behind bars or
um
she was doing lunges behind the car she
wound up behind bars
yeah yeah there we go yeah that rhymes
yeah
i weighed it
cool beans
thanks for sharing their coast and ghost
next
joke
uh but tronics
have you noticed how you compare the
world all right let's start over oh have
you noticed how you compare the word
super with another word and it doesn't
mean better
the meaning changes for example pair
super with visor and suddenly it means
[__]
got it yeah yeah so what if you let us
down there give us a couple example of
how it actually works
super
um
give us a couple of positive supers like
uh i can't think of my mind went blank
on super
it's like oh super cool super eventful
and then like but if you parrots or some
words it's totally negative it's like
supervisor means [__]
yeah yeah superhero maybe there's
something superhero hero is cool
supervisor or not
save superhero saves lives supervisor
ruins them
could be comparing those two as well
supermarket
crossfit in the crosswalk that was from
another the other joke but um
i like that supermarket superhero and
then and then and yet supervisor means
[__]
yeah if supermarket means big market
superhero means big you know superman um
then
why does supervisor mean [__]
cool though
funny funny observation there
uh next joke
jordan lieben
i love uber eats it's nice to give a
name
and face to the person coughing on my
friends
that's a good joke by itself i like that
oh
yeah you know and also let us know you
know i love when they they when they
their profile picture pops up with their
you know with their name it's like
because it's always good nice to give a
name and a face to the person coughing
on my french fries yeah yeah and the tag
he could be like five stars or
like there maybe is a tag there
five stars i got coven
yeah five stars i got five star coven
review or something uh yeah
so now i have a reason to use ubereats
yes the socially distance
i like it though yeah those are a few
tag ideas but i like the joke as is too
oh jordan said jerry laughing at my joke
just made my ear
oh that's like i love i love those uber
eats jokes because they're just like
they're so convenient but when they
screw up it's like such a such an
inconvenience you know
yeah i'm just thinking about how
inconvenient was that jordan said he
liked your laugh and not mine that's
really where my inconvenience came in
no it's all good
got that we got the the joke dr mafia in
here right now
oh payton said five out of five kovids
that's funny that's
good oh and we skipped ryan's
i don't see uh i don't see yours ryan
uh maybe repost it
or maybe sometimes youtube will flag a
joke if it has like a bunch of swear
words in it or something so try to like
put
like characters where like a potentially
like
um
triggering word would be
and that can usually get by uh cyrillius
uh i'm not the laziest person ever but
procrastination postponed my suicide i'm
getting better though i now plan my
tomorrows
so we got we got a joke and a tag here
um so it's like i'm not the laziest
person
i'm not the laziest person ever but
procrastination actually postponed my
suicide
um
so that's almost like top 10 reasons you
know you you procrastinate
you know it's like uh you know uh you
know i'm not the laziest person ever but
procrastination postponed my suicide
it's like um i'm getting better though i
now plan my
i plan my tomorrows um you can even meet
that
i i now make my pl and now make um
i you know i now plan minutes ahead or
now plan hours ahead rather than
you know or something you know what i'm
saying i now but plan my po tomorrow
this is a good place holder for now but
remember it's two jokes don't step over
that suicide pause
getting better though and now plan my
tomorrows
yeah let that breathe oh wait there's my
there's my alert wake up
i mean there's i you know this that's
that's the that's the
the that's the reminder oh got a
reminder
wake up
you know what i'm saying like you have
to set your reminder to wake up
oh i like that yeah setting alarm to to
that to live
in a way really flesh that out you can
go top 10 reasons you know your
procrastinator and just keep
tagging every one of those you know top
10 device that mechanism is a punchline
generator
from back in the joey bishop show days
in the 60s
top 10 reasons you you know your
mother-in-law hates you top 10 reasons
you know she's going to divorce you
i'm with it
oh and um
ryan skrillet we did read bite-worthy i
think bite worthy's joke which i think
is you as well
um oh and jordan said i'm his yoda okay
well i appreciate it after the fact i
appreciate now that i guilted him into a
compliment i'll take it either way
you're my yoda
hilarious
oh thank you
um
[Music]
let me see
next
joke
juan
medrano
heard from the dentist i have a bad
tooth
then the tooth he was talking about
started to hurt must have struck a nerve
or something the other teeth had no
problem with it tooth
was
an
sj dub
that uh what is sjw
what am i what am i missing i don't know
stroke of genius oh no that was that's a
different joke that was posted here i
don't know
no problem with it tooth was an sj dub
i don't know unless it's a typo
maybe juan can let us there's a there's
a couple of like heard from the dentist
have a bad tooth which is weird because
he's not even my dentist
just like
that's what you ever have that it's
almost like psychosomatic some guy's
like hey uh
it's like it's like that's how a dentist
cold calls
he says
justice warrior
social justice
social justice warrior okay i guess you
and i look so unwoke right now we're
just like two white guys like what's
that
yeah
must have struck a nerve or something
the other teeth had no problem with it
tooth was a social justice warrior
i kind of get what he's saying bad too
than the other two you know the the
tooth started to hurt i don't know maybe
there's a joke like his tooth being a
millennial and then it gets super and
then it makes it super sensitive and
adds a little more context to social
justice yes yes yeah
it's like yeah this tooth is super
sensitive yeah it must be a millennial
yeah yeah yeah yeah and that kind of
says the same thing it must be a gen z
cool
awesome
oh let me see if there's one more at the
buzzer maybe rick rick olson here this
may be the last one my friends so thank
you all so much for hanging out hey rick
look at that head shot rick yeah look at
that
uh he's got a halo
yeah man it's glowing
that man stole jesus's background
[Laughter]
so yeah we'll um
we'll land this uh plane after this one
thanks all for hanging out we do this
every single tuesday live on this
youtube channel so do subscribe and
come back with us next week we do three
live streams a week on this channel
and here we go rick olson
2016 nobel prize in physics awarded for
research into strange forms of matter my
favorite forms of matter
what the
and it don't
my favorite forms of matter
what's the matter and it don't matter
got it
do you think it's set up for a power of
threes like could he do like two
could he like kind of make an absurd one
for the third one
it's like matter of fact i was like
thinking of like uh my favorite forms of
matter it's like sometimes you have
we're on different
sometimes
especially if you set it up like we're
on different wavelengths
like sometimes i think uh if we're at
different wavelengths we we we can
actually interpret something somebody
says completely differently like this
this guy was like won the nobel prize in
physics for uh research into
strange forms of matter
you know i'm an english major my
favorite my favorite forms of matter are
what's the and it don't
you know what i'm saying but if he ties
in we need something to help us connect
his version versus the physics version
i'm an english major my favorite forms
of matter of what's the and it don't
yeah now we see you know english versus
physics
and it may not like all the nobel peace
prize stuff may not be i mean it could
just be like in physics they study
strange forms of matter in english
we don't know what's the matter or it
doesn't matter oh maybe
like physicists study strange form of
matter
um while most people say it doesn't
matter maybe there's like a word play
there of like it's it doesn't matter
either way i think he's writing a
configurational joke here though
and he wants the audience to sort of get
involved in the play of it you know
strange
matter
in physics
that's like that's you know that's
a strange form of matter different in
english where my strangest forms of
matter or what's the and it don't
and plus he was looking strange forms of
matter you're looking at favorite forms
of matter
you know but if you made it if you made
throw in that connector of english
that kind of an english major
my favorite forms of matter is what's
the and it don't
pause pause pause but remember anything
more than one and a half seconds for
configuration sometimes the laugh just
diminishes and falls off the planet you
know
yeah and rick said great connection
there so yeah awesome
well good
we got a lot of good jokes out there
today thanks go so fast doesn't it an
hour just flies right by that flew by
but we appreciate you so much with all
you have going on right now jerry we
really appreciate you sharing some time
here with the hot breath the verse
you're always a big celebrity hit when
you come through so thank you thanks
much
yeah next time next time we do it um
when paul and paula won't be on covid
i'll have that email earlier and we'll
be able to blast it out to the email uh
list and let people know it's here and i
again once again was not able to get it
out because she got like long term and
has been sleeping
oh yeah whatever yeah whatever she needs
to do to recover no worries at all i
just appreciate you jumping on here with
us and um
you you need to promote or anything or
you want people yeah well we got uh a la
carte classes are coming back we'll be
sending out some promotion on that soon
and i've got a new class for those
people who've already taken my
eight-week class we're now doing
a a performance and evaluation class
which has like been requested time and
time again i was like well i already
have that but
in this class what we're going to do is
like i took it i borrowed this idea from
an acting class where we would do the
scene at the first part of the class get
some notes and then do the scene again
and the leap
in
skill
just from the notes was so noticeable in
class some people had suggested me doing
that in the class there was just no time
so now if i take out the lecture and
writing part of it and just go right to
performance evaluation for the three
hours we can get to all the students in
the class and so i'll be doing that one
and people are excited about that so if
you've taken that class taken into
stand-up class with me that get that
performance and evaluation
is going to be uh is going to be really
a game changer i think to see people to
see the growth
yeah because that is the next and you
see it the same night rather than
waiting a week you know what i'm saying
yeah yeah that's what's going to say
like that is the next level it's like
you're writing but then also the
performing and how you're saying it is
kind of when you take it to that next
level your comedy so yeah i'm excited
you're doing that that's going to help a
lot of people
yeah
yeah so that's what we got going on
awesome well thank y'all thank you so
much jerry as always
thank you hot breath first for hanging
out y'all have a good night we'll be
doing this again next tuesday
yeah
right so just just hit me up with via
text if you ever need somebody to fill
in man and i'm i'm happy to join in with
you guys
comedy synergy baby comedy synergy
thanks for hanging out everyone you all
have a good night
[Music]
oh and sorry for any confusion for
everyone who's tuning in for the first
time or not exactly sure what we're
doing here
i just want to let y'all know because i
saw callie gertz had a question
this youtube channel it's part of our
podcast we have a podcast over 400
comedy interviews on there i'm a
comedian myself of over 12 years we have
over 400 interviews on our podcast and
this youtube channel we have podcasts
plus
three live streams a week
every tuesday at 5 pm eastern time we do
this joke feedback hour every wednesday
at 10 a.m i do a live joke writing
contest and every wednesday at 5 00 pm
i do a live q a which tomorrow we have
david arnold who just dropped a netflix
special produced by kevin hart he's
coming on to answer your comedy
questions at 5 pm eastern time
so do subscribe to this channel it's all
about comics help and comics if you love
jerry you're gonna love our channel and
love what we're doing here as well
but that is all my friends
so go forth
enjoy your wins your tuesdays my friends
and hopefully we'll see you tomorrow
morning or we'll see you back here next
week
yes david is a beast he's going to be
joining us live tomorrow at 5 00 pm
eastern time to answer your comedy
questions so come on
back but until then y'all have a good
day out there y'all keep grinding comics
i love you so much
[Music]